Hello, everybody!
My name is Markiplier and welcome to Bad Dream: Coma.
Now, I played the Bad Dream series years ago.
But this is the full release of the game.
It actually traverses the same locations as the other ones or so I've been told.
But going back to them, and I don't know the story of this, I barely knew the story in the first one
They were loosely connected, but they were connected because it all related to you being in a coma
and so we stand, at the gates of this new game fully released on Steam, and I have no idea
what's the  story.
But if you guys remember Bad Dream, it was a really, really cool series.
"Sweet Dreams"
Who's kissing me good night? O_O Where is my bedtime story?
okay I'll just drift off into blackness then.
That's fine.
Chapter one: the bridge.
Now if you remember, the ending of the first series of games
took place on a bridge. And I'm pretty sure it seems the same, but trust me, this is completely different.
Oh, do I really want to punch that crow?
Why do I want to punch this bird?
Never mind
That's exactly what I did. I don't know why I did that, but that's what happened
Why am I...I don't want to punch that!
I just punched those birds.
"Need any help? Visit us. We will help you for free!"
No catch. I'm sure they're--
Oh, that's so weird, ooh
Okay, bye, buddy. Oh that's weird.
Weather, heavy storm. You Goddamn liar
Bridge is closed. Oh, you goddamn liar
That's weird, whoa found something
Lug nut
killed Birds uh
Hello, hi, why why would you do that?
So the thing about this game is like. There's a lot of very minute--
Okay, bye. Did you hear about the crazed bird puncher?
I'll punch you right in your bird butt. Let's go up the bridge.
I did wha... bam. I'm crazy
I'm so sorry oh, I'm so sorry about that
Scloosh oh good I got that. What's that gonna do?
Controller active, great. What does that do?
"Why can't we wake up?" Good question!
Stop doing that. You gotta have a reason for that
Hello again Birds. Ooh, schdoosh.
Oh, well. That's gone. Well. That's gone
Break this goddamn bridge. Oh
Is there a pit to hell right in the middle of the bridge?
Oh, hi spidey.
Yeah, okay. Go to your pit of hell. Go back.
What are we looking at here?
Do I need to look at stuff? "Missing nurse. Where is she?" I don't know.
Hey, Nurse! Where'd you go?
I don't wanna--Oh God
What is that?
I'm sorry I punched your friends. It was an accident.
I swear! Okay, what's with the pit of hell?
Like what are we doing over there?
oops, well I'm
Destroying this goddamn bridge. Well, there we go. Oh that's so cool.
But there's so many minute things in the environment to click on.
Such an exploration game.
Well, I got keys. Oops. No that's not what I wanted to do.
Birds
Boink, I feel bad about this. Oh, I can't reach you
Yeah, you're lucky you're across that bridge.
You think you can mess with me?
Ooh, sock. What's this? "Lost? Sit our hospital!"
Alrighty, then. if you saw so.
I did not have to punch all those birds. I realize that now.
I did not have to punch those birds.
I am an asshole. Oh, what the hell? It's getting darker.
Why was it getting darker? Oh wait! The remote for this car.
There we go. Weee!
Oh, there we go. Oh, no! It got in a car accident?
Wait, what did that-? Did that actually have repercussions?
Why is it getting darker over there? Hey, I saw you!
God damn it. I saw you!
Status, oh, status. "Birds hate you." Yes, they do.
I've got blood on my hands and birds. Oh, no. Oh, no
I've already ruined it.
I've already ruined it for the bad end
I'm already gonna get the baaad end, and I didn't even know that.
Oh, no! Well fuck-a duckle me. Oh
My God, I've done wrong. I didn't want to punch the birds!
What's gonna happen? Aah?
Oh shit, hi. Oh
That is fucking weird. Oh
Oh, well, I guess I can unlock this.
Crowbar. Sure that makes sense.
I have a full-size crowbar from that. Man, should I go back and redo it?
I feel like I should.
I feel like I have to at this point. I have to do this again.
I'll be right back though.
I'll be right back. Good thing I checked that status, or are you birds-?
I'm not gonna punch you. I swear to God. I see you over there!
Okay
Hello again. I don't have blood on my hands now, so.
I won't touch your blood, all right.
Oh, thank you for this.
Ok, so now that I got the crowbar, and now that my endings are still available to me.
I didn't even know that was a thing that could happen. I'm gonna crowbar this.
Not kill no birds
Why did I do that? Oh, a bridge. I can use that to bridge the gap.
*gasps*
That seems
precarious, but I'm gonna go for--
aaaAAAAY
We're good.
Everything's fine.
Who just farted?
All right. You don't need to make fun of me.
Gonna go forward. Ah-oh
*faint crying*
Did somebody lose their baby?
That seems weird, but okay
Okay, so there's some electrical poles.
Oh, that's so cool
That's such a minor detail, but I appreciate it so much look the way lightning goes to my...
Oh, my little hero
That's so good. Oh, that's good stuff.
Okay. Anyway.
We got to get through this which means that we gotta
Jam this crowbar in there.
I don't know what we got to do. Oh
Wait, okay, so there needs to be something
Connecting that
To each other so I need like a piece of iron or something like that, right?
I gotcha, okay
We're again this baby
Little concern- oh hi, Baby. I
Saw that bag move but okay.
ooooooooohhhhh
Baby, want a bottle?
Didn't mean to do that. Oh, no. Oh, no
No, I didn't mean to, Oh, no!
That's not what I meant to do!
I thought it was all my god
Oh, no! Ah!
I gotta go back. Okay at least it's got me here.
Oh my God. I did not want to smash that baby
Why is there baby here? This game is messing with my brain.
Ooh, this game is ooh.So you can get a wire from that baby
Maybe I could... there we go. That's a much better option. Oh
That's a much better
Hi, baby. Could you stop staring at me like that because my God baby that is not okay?
Could you just stop staring at me? Oh my God baby. Oh?
well that
welp.
I'm gonna punch a bird in anger
what the hell do I do now? Why does this goddamn?
Why is it getting darker?
Oh my God over here over here oh, hi. Hello
We're oh you're looking for your crowbar I
I wasn't, give me something. Oh my god -
I left my crowbar here me something in return you want a bottle
Thank you. I didn't even know that. I didn't have it. How did you get that?
Oh?
I probably shouldn't do that. Oh well left my crowbar there, okay?
That's so weird. I love this game's attention to detail. That's really really cool. Oh well
It's like that was gonna happen anyway. I would have just broken it
Alright anyway. I guess I'll just meander.
Where'd this come from why is there a pap-
The f-...What, what is this?
What is this little paperclip?
oh, I gotta..oh
Well that nickel got fubernucked up. I don't understand okay ah like a lightning Rod
Ah, okay, that's weird, but I'll deal wi-I'll take-
Oh, hi.
You good man, you blind man with two toes sticking out?
Do you have some change?
I do!
There you are. Thank you so much.
Have a nice day.
I will! you too! take care
oh
What is that? I have a good heart?
Oh, what else would I have done, just punched him like all the birds I punched
Hey
Haha, I did it
I did it!
Yay!
Man, that's so weird
That's so weird. Oh
It's so weird
But anyway, that's chapter one complete now
I don't know how many chapters are in this game, but knowing the first series
I believe it was broken up into six parts.
So the next one is the hospital.
So we're gonna pick it up right there
I'm gonna try to maintain my good status
But I don't know how easy that's going to be thank you everybody so much for watching
I'll get to this game more
Real soon, so let me know what you think down the comments below and as always, I will see YOU in the next video
Buh-Bye!